some of those trusted shoes came back he  didn't want to hear it  at one point you walked away  so you woke up and he was gone yeah  he knows everything about me and my  family  i only know so much  he knows who i am as a person he doesn't  like it why do you propose  only to a point just to walk away and  leave me wondering  hanging  feels like it's happening at all okay  here we go again  that's exactly how i felt i can't be the  one always trying to patch it up  why should i feel guilty i'm just trying  to stay how i feel  if he doesn't like it oh well too bad is  that easy you just get up and go  i didn't throw him out he just walked  away  like running myself ragged  starting my life  you